And if you want to keep doing this, buddy, you could tell me
to check the scoreboard. I'll run circles around you on this,
dude. >> You're a loser. Congratulations. This is your
Piers Morgan debut, Adam. >> Adam, I'm 17 years old. I
have a I have a wife and children. Who depends on you, Adam?
Your mom?
DUDE, ABSOLUTELY BRUTALIZING HIM. What
This is Dave Smith versus Adam Sosnick.
Huh? Yeah, uh yeah. Uh yeah. Let's go. So more Dave Smith, host
of Part of the Problem, a libertarian who backed Trump in 2024.
And Adam Sosnick, who's the Valuetainment host and PBD podcast
regular, a former liberal who backed Trump in 2024. Well, welcome
to both of you. On this specific caller about Iran, I did say
on day one
I think this is a massive gamble, and I don't understand the
timing, and I think the capacity for this to go badly wrong is
very high. The longer it has gone on, cuz Trump originally was
like, this is over in days, then it's over in a couple of weeks,
then everything started changing, then the regime change he said
was going to happen with people rising up, none of that has happened.
There are lots of reasons for it. I think the reason we so many
pro-regime
people hit the streets was they were not going to get killed
doing it. We saw in January when people protested against the
regime, a lot got killed. And obviously there are bombs flying
around all over the cities
I'm so excited for Adam's answer on this. I'm so excited. Which
will also put people off, I guess. Uh so there are lots of reasons,
I guess, why people are protesting or not protesting in certain
ways. Um but that the to me, the justification for this war has
changed so many times. It's made me think I don't think Donald
Trump has any clear idea of what victory looks like. Do you?
I mean, if the if the regime remains intact and they keep their
enriched uranium, for example, and they maintain control of the
Straits of Hormuz, is that victory?
Well, look, the this was not an easy decision. You think, you
know, this guy Start off by not answering the question. Fantastic.
That's why
Piers needs to watch a Pisco debate. Yes or no, is this victory
in that case?
Answer first, then you can fill out time. Don't just talk in
circles with no answer at all. >> power 47 years. Everybody
in our microwave hustle society wants this done in the next 4
to 7 weeks. It's going to take some time. Nobody's denying that
10 to maybe 20% max of the country is
But what about the 80% of the country? That's like if Dave had
a comedy show, there was a hundred people that magically showed
up to Dave's comedy show. Oh my god, he has so many fans. Dude,
there's a hundred thousand people outside that didn't go to the
show. I'm not being like Brutus or sarcastic, but just you're
taking a small sample size and extrapolating that for the entire
country. We Well, actually, just to be to be clear, or hang on,
Adam, just to be I I I just to just to be technically correct
on that on that argument you're making, if a hundred people turned
up to watch Dave's show, then technically over eight billion
chose not to. Correct, and that's pretty uniform for the at this
point. [laughter] This is really making me feel bad about my
numbers on the road. I feel pretty good. The eight billion people
It doesn't mean there are eight billion people Also looks like
he's having a stroke right now. Look how big his Look how big
his pupil is versus this one. Like he's blown a pupil.
Like just turning into How do you become like this kind of Israel
shill who's just offuscating, who's just like like literally
can't answer a question. Just going to talk in circles as much
as he possibly can. People don't know why I used to own a couple
No, it's fine. I mean, I actually do like Dave Smith. Let me
tell you a Dave Smith story. I actually have respect for Dave
Smith. Um but I I realized who Dave Smith is, and I I would say
this to his face or on camera. Dave Smith is a radical
libertarian. Don't take my word for it. You've said this multiple
times. Have you not, Dave Smith?
Said what? That I'm a radical libertarian? Yes, absolutely. >> Okay.
Yes. Okay, perfect. So when you're something when you're radical
What what I believe in it What what I believe in is true
>> Okay. This is why you're you call America a terrorist
terms. This is why you call
Sure. This is why you call uh the US military the greatest terrorist
organization on Earth, right? Because you're a true American,
cuz you're a true patriot. Is that why, Dave? Because something
tells me you have what is known as clickbait of the mouth. United
States is the greatest terror organization in the world has ever
seen? I mean, I don't understand what's going on here. This is
why you're radical. So by the way, I'll tell you what I'll tell
you what. Hang on, just to be fair to be fair to Dave, let's
replay what he actually said on this show, and I'll play you
what Shapiro said about it, and then we'll come back to Dave
for for response.
The IDF is the worst terrorist organization in the region. Let's
get real. The United States of America is arguably the worst
terrorist organization in the world. If you want to look over
the last 25 years, how many innocent civilians we've slaughtered.
It doesn't matter, it turns out, how many times you appear on
Joe Rogan's show, or how many times you hide behind your title
of comedian who holds the Guinness Book of World Records for
fewest jokes told, or how many times you spew puerile analogies
that demonstrate nothing but unbelievable willful ignorance of
the nature of war.
Dude, is Ben really throwing the first stone on being incapable
of comedy?
You know his first career was as a writer in Hollywood, right?
This guy has been successful at everything in life except making
people like him, okay? That's the one thing he's totally failed
at. Now, I know that Dave Smith is super duper excited that his
name was mentioned here, and he's sitting there shouting at his
TV screen in his basement, "Debate me, bro." To which I answer,
"Nah." I don't debate with trolls who claim that America is the
biggest terror state in the world because that is idiotic.
So Dave, as you know, that all blew up. A lot of debate raged
about it. Just tell me, clarify what you what you meant. Do you
regret phrasing it the way you did? Just give us a little more
meat on the bone.
Uh no, I don't I don't regret phrasing it the way I did, and
I'll I'll be very clear about what I'm saying. I will I will
point out that it's it's quite something for Ben Said arguably
in the last 25 years, by the way. So Adam, Adam was histrionic,
Ben was histrionic, they're both histrionic.
Right? They're both They both have to hyperbolize what Dave Smith
said cuz they they get in their feelings. >> Shapiro, just
since you played him, I got to respond to him first. That he
goes, "Oh, I just won't debate with this guy because this is
so beyond the pale." Ben Shapiro made his name debating 19-year-old
communist Maoists who were confused about their gender. So somehow,
Piers, we're we're going to have to believe here that I'm so
much less serious than the children who Ben Shapiro made a career
debating. I loved your response to him where you pointed out
some of the goofy segments that he does on his show. I mean,
personally, I really stay away from that stuff. And um you know,
for Adam I think to say it's clickbait or that I just want to
get out in front of the camera, I think we're all equally in
front of a camera right now, and it's kind of weird to accuse
someone else I very much believe the things I'm saying. Now,
to Adam's point, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on,
cuz there's a bunch of you Let me Let me Let I'm trying to get
to you, but there's a lot of people Well, he wanted to [__]
on Ben Shapiro. Hey, we all love Do not interrupt this man. He's
cooking Ben Shapiro right now. Shut the [__] up,
Adam. Let him This is the one time I've enjoyed Dave Smith, okay?
This is the one SINGLE TIME. DO NOT INTERRUPT HIM in this moment.
Good, you're taking Let's go. Wrap it No, I'm going to make the
points I want to make. You called You called the United States
military You're just slowing Okay, so anyway, I'm going to go
to the example of the greatest He said He said He should have
actually just said, "I'm going to restart with the everything
I was going to say about Ben Shapiro." So I loved how Piers cooked
Ben Shapiro for being a deeply unserious person. He goes to college
campuses and fights college students well into his late 20s because
those are his intellectual equals, okay? So if he's going to
treat me like I'm less than a college student, like I'm less
informed, which Dave Smith could also be, by the way. Dave Smith
is I watched that Dave Smith debate with Andrew Wilson. That
was horrible for him, okay?
But I He should start all over again. Adam defend Just let me
answer. Now, for me to say what I made the point I've made this
point a million times on your show, Piers. I'm saying when people
come on and say Iran is the biggest state sponsor of terrorism,
well, just like give me an objective definition of what terrorism
means, and then let's apply that standard universally. And if
you're going to sit here and
>> Dude, it's so easy, right? It's so free every time.
Yeah, just give me a definition that includes Iran, but doesn't
include the United States or Israel. Go ahead. This terrorism
should be like
Yeah, just give me give me that definition cuz I was
It's It's basically they'll go, "Well, but it's a brutal regime
that cracked down on people." Okay, so
any authoritarian regime is is a terrorist state. That's not
what terrorism is. In fact, terrorism is usually applied outward.
Doesn't have to be, but it's usually applied outward. It's usually
not the government, right? That's usually how people start with
the definition. >> America has given billions, tens of
billions of dollars to the IDF in the last few years. We've also,
by the way, given a lot of weapons and money." Here your first
guest on this show there, the head of the Obama deep state, was
using Al-Qaeda Bin Ladenite head choppers on the ground in Libya
and in Syria. And yes, Adam, I would also consider it when our
politicians lie us into wars that slaughter millions of innocent
people, and in many cases target those innocent people, I consider
that terrorism as well. There's the answer, Adam. And if you
want to keep doing this, buddy, you could tell me to check the
scoreboard. I'll run circles around you on this, dude. Check
the scoreboard. Most unpopular war in American history going
in. Check the scoreboard. 13 dead Americans and 150
plus other wounded. Thousands of innocents including little school
girls in Iran killed. It it dead
Did Dave Smith actually kind of cook it? What the
When did Dave Smith learn how to argue? I guess with enemies
like this, but >> Israel. Hundreds of dead innocent people
in in Lebanon. Millions of innocent people being displaced all
at the cost of tens of billions of dollars and destroying Trump's
coalition. Check your scoreboard, Adam. How's it looking for
Okay, Dave. So, okay. It's not working well for you, Dave, because
you're still saying that United States You're saying that you're
saying the United States is a terror
>> organization. You've already lost the debate. You live
in It's it's a Adam Adam Carolla is deploying like the Nicholas
D'Orio tactic, okay? This is unironically
Are you saying that like Are you saying this thing that's like
weird and I I think it's like weird? You're saying a weird thing.
You lost. You lost. You just said a weird thing. You're kind
of weird, man. You're like a weirdo. Have you thought about how
weird you are?
So, Dave says, "Substantively respond to anything I said." And
Adam goes, "You called the United States a terrorist organization.
You lost already. You said something weird."
Dude, shut up. >> in America, tough guy. You have the luxury
of sitting in your little studio I'm saying the regime the regime
like you're 17 years old. The regime, do you mean all American
presidents? Who's your favorite president in the last 50 years?
Adam, I'm 17 years old. I have a I have a wife and children.
Who depends on you, Adam? Your mom?
>> ABSOLUTELY BRUTALIZING HIM. WHAT THE HOLY [laughter]
SH
ADAM LEWIS JUST GOES, "WELL, YEAH. YEAH. My mom."
>> Okay. I I mean, you want If you want to make it personal,
so you want to go personal? >> You have a significant other,
okay? >> Yeah, we can go personal as we can go No, I'm
trying not to. YOU'RE A MIAMI [__] BOY. YOU GOT A
SIGNIFICANT OTHER. I bet you got eight significant others. I'm
a family man, [__] Don't come at me about who I care
about or who I take care of or what my priorities are. You know,
let's try to respond to one thing. >> care, Dave. I don't
care. >> CUZ YOU DON'T KNOW ANYTHING. SO, move on. So,
stop picking a fight with me, dude. You don't know anything about
How about you go pick up waitresses in in that food truck or
sorry, at that restaurant you own part of, okay? Go pick up some
waitresses. I know that's why you bought that restaurant so you
could 18-year-old waitresses in Miami, you piece of [__]
We all see you. We've all met somebody like you. This totally
soulless corporate shill, this salesperson. You are scum. You
are actual scum.
>> You're Pat's guy. I know Okay, that might have been
a little personal. I might know somebody like Adam and I might
be projecting a little bit of that, but but I do believe that
basically everything I said there is correct. I would bet money
that what I said there is correct. Not joking. >> what
I I like you. I like your show. I respect Pat. Dave, okay. Zay
Zay zip it. Here we go. I'll talk now for a second. I'm defending
the military right now. You're basically saying that all our
boys in uh that Dave probably know better. Wait, what is that?
Wait, why is Dave no better? I've seen no indication that Dave
around? Have we seen any indication that Dave around? I've seen
Adam when when streamers are streaming in Miami. I've seen Adam
out with random people.
You know exactly, dude.
Everything about him is like on the surface. He's There's nothing
below the surface there, okay? He's got no depth. There is nothing
about him that is This is he This is everything. This suit, this
presentation, that's all of Adam. There is nothing else there,
okay? >> Dave, okay. Zay Zay zip it. Here we go. I'll talk
now for a second. I'm defending the military right now. You're
basically saying that all our boys in that go to the military
are all terrorists. I need to stop I need to start calming down.
I'm [__] my voice up screaming, man. I But, these
people actually anger me. I actually have anger. I'm like actually
just destroying my [__] voice
screaming about these people. I'll talk now for a second. I'm
defending the military right now. You're basically saying that
all our boys in that go to the military are all terrorists. That's
what you're saying. You're equating that the United States of
America, the IDF are the equivalent of ISIS and Al-Qaeda. By
the way, I also used to respect you until until you went on a
little All all the military personnel are totally propagandized.
Or a part of cults like the Christian Zionist cult. They're just
totally propagandized. Dave doesn't hate them. No libertarian
would hate them.
Cuz they're they're getting the worst end of the bargain, by
the way. Dave isn't getting the worst end of the bargain. The
people who believe the lies that you tell them of the United
States and its military are the ones getting the worst end of
the bargain, okay?
Not Dave. Dave gets to sit here and go, "That's really [__]
up." He doesn't have to go die in Iran. He doesn't have to go
sit on Kharg Island when this deal when Israel inevitably hits
something and makes Iran strike back and they wipe out Kharg
Island before getting Tehran nuked, okay? Dave's not a part of
that equation. Dave gets to sit in America nice and comfy.
podcast called Coleman Hughes. What happened on that podcast,
Dave? This is the problem.
Respond to anything I said substantively. What happened on a
little podcast called Coleman Hughes, Dave? Dave just laughs
at him. Just laughs in his face. You're a [__] loser.
Congratulations. This is your Piers Morgan debut, Adam.
You've exposed yourself as a [__] to anybody who
watches. You are the biggest loser.
>> Why don't you do it right now, Adam? Why don't you do
it? I'll do it I'll do it right now, Dave. I'll do it right now.
Cuz here's what Dave is. Here's Dave Here's Dave Smith. By the
way, 1% of Americans vote for libertarians every year. So, you're
trying to basically say that you know more than the average American.
1% of Americans vote for your people, Dave. Why don't you run
for something? Why don't you stand for something? You stand for
nothing. THERE'S NO WAY. YOU'RE A LIBERTARIAN. You're stupid.
Okay, so why don't you debate him on the substance? Why don't
you debate him on the issue? >> You're You're a dumb libertarian.
Yeah, and you're getting by a dumb libertarian right now. More
fool you, my friend. Okay. Can I respond? Again, Piers, this
is the level of substance
No, no. >> Here we go. I'm going to tell you a story, Dave,
and then you can respond cuz this is where I lost respect for
you as a debater. Cuz I was like, "Oh, this guy Dave, he actually
knows some stuff. He's doing his thing." And then you showed
up on Coleman Hughes podcast.
Piers, do you know who Coleman Hughes is? I do. He's been on
my show. I've been on the show with him. Perfect.
Perfect. That's this guy RIGHT HERE.
HE'S DOING THE DAVE Rubin thing. Um let's just clip of you right
here. Look at this clip. Do you see this clip on my phone right
now?
>> But, what is the point you're making?
Oh, he he couldn't even hold the clip up cuz he's Dude.
Hey, Adam, in the future, I'm pretty sure if you want to have
a clip on the show, you could just send it to Piers's producers.
They'd be perfectly happy to throw that on the screen for you.
Adam just keeps embarrassing himself.
This is This might as well be Adam like a picture of Adam spreading
his cheeks open, okay? >> guy right here. Just in case.
Please please don't hurt me, Mr. Dave Smith, sir. And he shows
the picture. But, what is the point you're making?
And this is this is Dave's response, by the way.
Every time Adam tries to make a point, Dave just gets to laugh
at him for being a [__] [__]
the point is this. Dave Dave gets out there and he tries to bully
people and say that he's so smart. He reads a lot. A lot of books.
Good for you, Dave. But, what happens? I don't mind Dave right
now. From watching Dave in the past,
Dave is not that smart, okay? Dave is Dave is not that smart.
I'm sorry, Adam. He's not that smart. You're just getting obliterated
right now by a guy who doesn't He doesn't really know that much.
He might have read two or three books. Listen, he might have
read that Common Sense paper from Thomas Paine,
but he he's not read a ton, all right? He's not that good a debater.
When you read it to somebody, run into somebody who's way smarter
and bullies the bully. I remember growing up in this town of
Miami, so it was this kid who used to pick on all the kids that
that we were at school
There's something weird about Adam trying to pretend that he's
PBD. This could almost be endearing from PBD.
This is not endearing from Adam.
PBD is like an old boomer who tells you a story, okay? Adam,
you're like 30. You're like a young man, okay? In in the context
of like this sphere, you are a young man.
Trying to go, "Well, back in my day." Shut up, man. You you you
suck so badly. Why are you doing the Elizabeth Warren boomer
story tell? go with. And one day some new kid showed up and he
goes, "Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Let's go, buddy. Let's do this."
And the bully goes, "Oh, what do you mean? What do you want to
do?" And he goes, "No, yeah. You want to fight everybody? You
want to take everybody's lunch? Let's go." And the new kid beat
the crap out of the bully. And here's what happened with Dave.
He's out there Oh, Adam is 46? Wait, Adam is 46?
No
There's no way he's that old.
I thought he was like I thought he was like 35.
just doing his little podcast thing debating like you said Ben
Shapiro 19-year-olds. And then all of a sudden this whole conversation
about Wesley Clark and I saw him on 46? He's 46?
Okay, never mind. I take back everything bad I said about Botox,
okay? I I take back every bad thing I said about Botox from before,
I take it all back. Holy
I should get some of this Botox go. What the a week ago, Piers,
and this memo, here you go, Dave. Remember this memo from Wesley
Clark that you used to cite everything? that you used to cite
Yeah. That is adorable because you're >> based on some
memo.
Oh, you're so precious. You're you're like a little baby. You're
so precious. foundation based on some memo.
What is the point you're making? The point is that [laughter]
Dave has zero credibility at this Dude, Piers, why did you do
that, dude? Dude, Piers.
Piers, that's so [__] up. Adam, just what are you
What are you doing? What are you trying to say? Nobody understands,
Adam.
Dave has zero credibility at this And he ran into the audience
gets to
What audience? The four people that showed up to your comedy
show at the
Yeah. Okay, Dave, you Dave, you respond. Can I Can I respond
now cuz I listened well I mean the question I Did his voice crack?
Did he just stop
Okay, Dave, you Dave, it's the four people that showed up to
your comedy show at the
Dude, his voice breaks and he can't talk. Dude, I can't. I can't.
Okay, [laughter] Dave, you Dave, you respond. Can His voice is
gone. He's like barely choking out words.
Yeah. Okay, Dave, you Dave, you respond. Can I Can I respond
now cuz I listened well I mean the question
Big sip. Big big sip right there. question I'll ask you, Dave.
Is the way the way that you're Let me respond to some of that,
Piers. I'll put it to you just on a general level. How are you
going to respond to a Coleman WHO BODIED YOU?
LET HIM RESPOND. WELL, YOU AIN'T WELL, you ain't doing nothing,
bro. You're sitting here just talking about what another man
did. You've already been in a body bag, Dave. I'm here to clean
up the scraps. Okay, let me just ask Dave
>> which is as you know that that the comment you
This is every
Every person I know who's like Adam who who's done sales, okay?
Every single person like this, they are entirely like flash.
They are just saying like what they think sounds cool.
It's so funny that he's being exposed like this. You're already
in a body bag, Dave. I'm just here to clean up.
Okay. Okay, man.
Cool. This could have been a tweet. That could have been a tweet.
you made about the last couple of years and so that went pretty
viral. Do you understand why a lot of people got very angry about
the perceived equivalence between America and terror organizations
like ISIS, like Al-Qaeda, and so on? Yeah, no, well, listen,
I mean, there's no question that that head chopping is But go
ahead. Hey, Adam Adam, I mean, just let me talk now. I know I
understand all you can do here is interrupt and hold up progress
and all that, but let me make a few good points. >> I'm
just You said that America's a terrorist organization. You've
already lost the debate. Go ahead. No, I haven't
and that's not You don't really get to decide in the middle of
the debate whether I have. It's who moves people more than the
other one is really, I guess, the metric. Um but
Dude, it's so [__] up that Adam Sosnick has somehow
made Dave Smith likable. I I like Dave Smith. What is happening?
What is happening?
It's all It's all Adam Sosnick. It's so [__] up.
I've never liked Dave Smith before in my entire life. He is He
is a thousand times more likable. He's making way better points.
It's actually crazy.
Dude, hold on, I got to look at the
That Who depends on you? Your mom line was brutal. You could
see Adam's soul leave his body.
>> I have to believe PBD is embarrassed by this. PBD just
sent a text to Adam, let's talk. [laughter] Fireside chat with
Adam Sosnick.
Adam should have to pay Israel $9,000 after his performance.
Dude, oh my god.
I mean I mean Adam, I under This will just be your tactic for
the rest of it cuz you're out of any You're just out of your
depth, but here. Okay, yes, actually, I didn't vote for the Libertarian
nominee. Donald Trump came Donald Trump came to the Libertarian
Party Convention and tried to convince a lot of us to support
him, and I'm one of the people who did, and now I'm one of the
people who's criticizing this policy. Now, in in terms of obviously,
Piers, it's a provocative statement. I know that when I make
it, and I'm not claiming that the that the American military
men are the equivalent of ISIS or Al-Qaeda. Obviously, they're
much more barbaric. These head choppers, the one who Leon Panetta
and and Barack Obama all sold weapons to and partnered with,
and the one who Donald Trump recognizes the president of Syria.
I'm not saying that they don't One isn't more barbaric than the
other. I'm simply making the point, Piers, that if you define
terrorism as targeting civilians in order to affect a political
change, then by that objective definition, the US military and
the IDF are more guilty of it than anyone else over the last
25 years. So, if someone wants to argue with me Their argument
is always that the US military and the IDF do not deliberately
target civilians. >> but again But I'm just I'm just saying
I'm just saying You can keep telling me
You can keep telling me that, but you're just asking me not to
trust my own lying eyes every single time. That's what you're
saying. Do not trust your lying eyes. They They don't intentionally
target civilians. Civilian apartment. They don't intentionally
target civilians, okay?
They don't intentionally target
Oh, the uh the the bombing entire?
Were there solar panels flying off of the building? I don't even
know.
They don't intentionally target civilians. They just continue
to bomb people in civilian areas. They just continue to totally
destroy civilian
Guys, but they don't target They don't target civilians.
Come on. I get the benefit of that. But that's not true.
Whereas whereas the difference Oh, also, I'm going to keep making
this point until somebody until somebody engages with it. Infrastructure
is equivalent to lives.
Guess what pays for the infrastructure? Taxes. Guess what people
get taxes. They spend their lives working, earning money, and
paying for things. Infrastructure is life.
Blowing up every bridge because you really hate the [__]
You really hate Hezbollah. That's not acceptable.
Blowing up a bunch of power stations, not acceptable.
Infrastructure is life. You don't get to flatten entire areas
and then say, "Well, we We tried not to We told them we were
going to blow it up." No, I don't care.
Guess what? September 11th, if they gave you an hour heads up,
September 11th is still bad. They say, "Hey, we're blowing that
up. Get out of those towers." And then only, you know, 2% of
the people
It's obviously not as bad, but it is still terrorism.
What do you think that does to the people who see that you can
take down something like that with no reprisal?
That's the goal. You are terrorizing. being that genuine terror
groups like ISIS, like Al-Qaeda, they deliberately and brazenly
target civilians for political purpose.
Piers, when we have when you have roaming blackouts for 9 days
in Cuba because we've embargoed the energy that can go there,
I'm sorry, that is targeting the civilian population. When Hamas
slow rolls the remains of dead
uh prisoners Kind of the same concept in Iran, too, unfortunately,
that nobody wants to hit on cuz the Iranian regime Basically,
if you if you say this, they'll accuse you of simping for terrorists,
right? But it really is the same thing in Iran that those people
were pushed into the streets by brutal economic sanctions,
And that's And the regime cracked down. Yes, they did.
But they were pushed out there. 100% they were. prisoners Excuse
me, um um
whatever I don't know. I get in trouble for using the wrong word.
The dead Israelis that they were holding captive even after all
the live ones are out, and the response from the Israeli government
is we're going to cut the aid to the civilian population in half,
that is targeting civilians. And when you drop bombs all over
cities and you know that innocent civilians are going to be killed,
that's targeting civilians. Now, as far as some of the other
stuff here,
in terms of the debate with Coleman, I encourage people to go
watch that. It's only people who already disagreed with me going
in who say I got body bagged there. The rest of the people tend
to say, "It was a kind of a good respectful back and forth, and
both people had some moments." But for for Adam to say I only
debated children up until Coleman, I debated Dennis Prager, I
debated Douglas Murray, I debated Josh Hammer in an Oxford-style
debate at Princeton University and absolutely smoked him on the
Oxford-style voting. I debated him
is he going to talk about the Andrew Wilson or one of his Wait,
did he debate Destiny? I think he did. I can't remember how his
I think it was It was on Piers, wasn't it? Wasn't it
Dave Smith and someone? Was it Dave Smith and and
>> the Alaska governor? Sarah Palin? Was it Dave Smith
and Sarah
Dave Smith got to go there, okay? Wait, didn't Dave I think Dave
basically turned on Sarah in that, didn't he? It's actually kind
of rough.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Now I'm remembering it.
Yeah. Yeah. It was It was kind of shitty. Okay. Okay. But he
the Andrew Wilson debate I'm getting at Charlie Kirk's event.
I have I've been coming on this show. How many debates have me
and you done, Piers? I've been willing to debate whoever wants
to debate this subject for over 2 years now. And so, to to say
that I'm just being Ben Shapiro and going around to college campuses
and debating 19-year-old dudes in wigs claiming to be women is
just not true, man. I I debated Chris Cuomo right in front of
you, Adam, the biggest host at CNN. So, I just think this is
ridiculous. Coleman made some Listen, I'm not going to say a
negative thing about Coleman. She didn't attack me. He went at
the issues, and I really appreciate and respect that. I've actually
been trying to host him on my podcast. I I hope he'll do it.
Okay, Adam, your response. Yeah, and what and and Listen, I do
respect that the fact that Dave does show up. He does. >> that's
like, okay, cool. You showed up. Respect to that. I I will give
Dave credit. But Dave, and and this is why I'm going to keep
going back to this. To pretend that it was an even Don't don't
That's This is why
This is why you shouldn't even Don't even talk. Don't even respond
Adam. Just go, that was your impression, that's fine. I encourage
people to go watch it, right? Don't say you didn't lose. Just
say, if that was your impression, that's fine. I encourage people
to go watch it.
Cuz now Adam's successfully reframed this from something he was
getting totally owned to is Dave Smith
Did Dave Smith win? And it's going to be totally subjective.
Stick to the facts. Keep talking about Israel blowing up civilian
infrastructure, buildings, using sanctions to force people out
into the street, and then if something bad happens to those people,
using that as a pretext to for going to war. Talk about >> Way
better. >> debate. He put you in a body bag, and you're
out here still still doubling down on all your positions when
he went methodically
and surgically >> the I've never been in a debate where
someone just fell back to someone else's debate. Boom, boom,
boom. What Name one of the booms. Make the point for yourself.
Me and you are supposed to be debating here, brother. >> from
Wesley Okay, now he's now he's getting owned again. Adam Adam
really shifted the conversation something insubstantial, and
he's getting owned again. >> Wesley Clark, the the memo
from Wesley Clark, your whole foundation
for your Israel So, listen up, little guy. So, your whole foundation
Israel dragging America into war
was that this memo from Wesley Clark showed up, and that's the
reason
I have no idea, Krieger. I have no idea what the debate was.
>> that America got suckered into the Iraq war cuz Israel
convinced them to do it, and he went and surgically and methodically
and very calmly was like, Dave, you don't know what you're talking
about. Your entire foundation
crumbled. And you're doing you're doing your little thing where
Can I respond to this? So, but the point is this. You're You're
Holland's open this 3-hour
debate with with Coleman Hughes. It wasn't close, Dave. And that's
fine. You want to sort of be a revisionist
Memo underlines did. This is what would happen to Professor Young.
Yeah. This is like Adam is a genuine Professor Young fan. I can
tell. He's got to be, right?
He underlined the word missile. He underlined the word Islamic.
He under said He underlined the word religion. Oh my god, he
circled it. Oh my god, he circled religion.
Boy, he's so cool. I'm not being >> for point. No, Dave,
that was any person WITH LOGIC
>> ADAM, IT IS AN UNUSUAL position to spend >> It's not
ridiculous. >> Adam, it's an unusual position that I've
had you guys on Because that's That was the MOMENT FOR ME WHERE
I SAID, THIS GUY IS ACTUALLY A
HE'S [laughter] ACTUALLY A LIGHTWEIGHT.
WELL, THIS IS THIS IS THAT MOMENT for you, for a lot of people,
Adam, so congratulations. My point to you, Adam, is simply that
it's an [laughter] unusual debating strategy to spend 10 minutes
of this debate talking about another debate that most viewers
may not
Yeah, it's it's pretty ridiculous. >> there's other debates
that we Literally just Yeah, Piers just makes the point great.
That was a great way to make the point without seeming biased.
Although, it seems like Piers is starting to get
Uh other Other viewers Sorry, viewers here may not have seen
that debate. Could you basically argue the point that Coleman
did and why Dave was wrong or let Dave argue the point back?
Why don't you argue the points specifically? Like, have the argument,
and then we can just watch it play out the same way. Or you can
call it where Dave had to change. >> bring up the fact
Dave, when's the last time you were in the
Okay, so this is what you're falling back to now. Yeah, right.
No, you know the answer. You're not asking.
I've asked it a million times, and you know the I have not been
to the Middle East. Go do your best Douglas Murray acting job.
Adam Adam, brother, I was prepared to come in here on friendly
terms. You You are humiliating yourself right now,
You are humiliating yourself right now. You've been humiliating
yourself
for the past 2 years. Basically saying that America's a terrorist
organization, that the IDF is a terrorist organization, and you're
whitewashing
Can I just ask like Again, I never heard Adam talk about Israel
the entire time he used to do
like Twitch poll, Destiny, Sargon of Akkad, and stuff. I never
heard him mention Israel. Why does he have to sneak in that the
IDF isn't a terrorist organization either? All the time.
Can anyone explain that? I like Okay, I get it. You're trying
to argue like Well, don't call Americans terrorists. Don't call
America terrorists.
But then he just keeps sneaking in this part about the IDF. Why?
Why? I don't know what's going on with his teeth here. We'll
We'll see if it fixes it. >> actual terrorism
What are your thoughts on Islamic terrorism coming into the West?
What are your thoughts on the war in the West? What do you think
of ISIS? It's a huge Are you Are you asking me questions? >> Go
ahead. >> It's a huge It's a huge I'm asking you a question.
And it's a huge It's a huge risk, especially right now after
we just murdered an ayatollah and his whole family. What's a
huge What's a huge Blowback terrorism is a huge problem at
Oh, let me ask you not to your borders. Nice try. I'm not talking
about blowback
I'm not talking I'm not talking about terrorism.
Do you see what's going on in in the West? Do you see what's
going on where Piers Morgan lives in London? Do you see what's
going on all over the I've been an advocate of strict immigration
controls for many years. And by the way, I'm not doing that.
You're just making stuff up cuz you have nothing, dude. And by
the way, I have nothing here, man. You just said that America
is a terrorist organization.
These things could both be true. You could say America's a terrorist
organization. I don't like any of these stinky Muslims in my
country. You could be a virulent racist and say that America's
a terrorist organization.
All that takes is admitting that the people you hate because
you're racist are human beings with souls that like some level
of empathy and concern.
Can you do that for Muslims? It sounds like the only way you
make your arguments, Adam, is if you have no empathy or concern.
You have You don't think those people are human. That's the only
way you can make your arguments,
Dave, just a And trust me, you don't you don't have to be racist
to want immigration control. But even if it were like just the
most virulent racist bigotry, I hate these Muslims. I hate Muslims.
I don't want them in my country. Even if Dave was saying that,
it doesn't mean America's not a terrorist organization. It doesn't
mean he can't accept that those people's lives matter, okay?
The only way you can argue what Dave Sorry, what Adam is arguing
is if he don't think those lives matter. A libertarian in favor
of strict immigration policy, interesting. Yeah, this goes back
to he's not a very good
>> If you brought He couldn't answer the big the highlight
of the Andrew Wilson debate was that he couldn't answer the hypothetical
that is
would you have the state intervene if a brother and sister who
were both adults wanted to have sex with each other? Or I think
it was even if two gay brothers wanted to have sex with each
other. Would you let the state intervene? He's like, do you think
that's wrong? Do you think it's morally wrong that the state
should intervene there? And I think he he basically tripped on
that question. That's like the classic do you think the state
has no no role to play unless there's harm, right? And he he
flubbed that one.
He also couldn't define the non-aggression the non-aggression
pact. Amazing. Oh, my country. He's anti-American, and here I
am as a proud American saying that he doesn't know what he's
talking about. >> that you said that they couldn't talk
about the Middle East cuz he hasn't been there much. Have When
was the last time you were in England? I spent many much time
in England. My ex-wife was When was the When was the last time?
Now, this is like the classic No, Canadian caller, this is like
the classic example that people use, right? Come up with the
most disgusting moral morally confounding question you can that
technically leads to no harm, that like technically could be
considered consenting adults in the same room. I think necrophilia
is another one that's like technically people aren't really being
harmed there, right? Krieger, when was the last time? The last
time
Hold on. I spent many much time in England. My ex-wife was When
was the When was the last time? >> a sheep shagger. When
was the last time? The last time The last time I was in
Dude, he's dying.
He just keeps choking over and over >> The In Europe, in
England, in the Middle East, where would you like me to go? >> No,
England. England. The last time I was in England was about 8
years ago. Right. So, this idea Let me tell you something. [laughter]
Let me tell you something. The last time I was in Israel Yeah.
was 3 years ago, Adam. There is a weird There is a weird idea
Do we have to put this episode out? Look, Adam, we don't have
to have this debate.
[laughter] no. Dude, it's actually hard to tell
how bad somebody's doing in the moment. Adam is doing horribly,
and that's totally fair. Oh, there Many people on the Are you
saying that that not going to a country Adam Many people Hang
on. Many people on the conservative right in America seem to
have the delusion that my country has been taken over by radical
Muslims. Let me tell you, I have lived here on and off for the
last 8 years, unlike you, and respectfully, we have not been
taken over by radical Muslims. It just hasn't happened the way
it's been sold by people like Tommy Robinson to Americans. And
you're all lapping it up. How would you How would you define
it then, Piers? How would you define it then, Piers? I think
we have a Muslim population which is predominantly peaceful and
inclusive and a settled one. Okay, and he sounds good. He sounds
like he's coping a little bit when he says inclusive, okay? I'm
going to be real. I believe that they're peaceful.
I don't necessarily believe that they're inclu- It depends on
what you mean by inclusive, I guess. I'm sure some of them are
really nice. They'll have a drink with you at the bar, right?
>> Well, and we have some radical members of of
radical Muslims, as we have radical members of other religions
>> remember that. in this country. And we have to be very
wary about it. >> what other what other members of radical
what other what other members of radical
And we have had and we have had severe immigration control issues
run by successive conservative and Labour governments who frankly
lost control of our border both to illegal immigration, but also
allowed way too many people in legally. And these are proper
legitimate things to be discussed. But framing it, as some people
like to do, as my country's been overrun and overtaken by radical
Muslims, is just a lie. It's just not true. Oh, right. Right,
I forgot about the whole prohibition on alcohol thing. True,
they might not drink with you. True. >> So, yes, there
are things to be concerned about, and yes, I want to see I want
to see everyone who comes here assimilate and everyone who lives
here assimilate into our culture, of course. So, I guess Adam
has just done even attempting to make the argument in favor of
Israel, right? Like I guess it's actually
It's actually just impossible to make, so Adam will refuse to
make it.
There's there's just no argument to be made. Fantastic. >> Of course
I do. But this idea that we've been overrun and overtaken is
nonsense.
Yeah. Piers, can I just make a quick >> is saying about
about Sharia law being imposed in in London and Birmingham. You're
saying that it's overblown? >> It hasn't been imposed here.
Okay,
You're saying that you're saying that it's over There are a number
of unofficial Sharia courts operating. They have no legal basis
or standing in the UK whatsoever. There is no Sharia law being
operated legally in this country. End. It doesn't It doesn't
happen. >> Piers. Thank you for enlightening me. So, you're
saying it's all overblown, that Why don't you come over Come
over with the whole PBD team and let me take you on a guided
tour of the UK and trust me, you'll be fine.
I'm
sure you're not going to Birmingham or the most dangerous places
in Piers. I'm sure you're not going to Birmingham or Brick Lane
or anything like that. >> Dude, there's got to be some
some hypotheticals you could come up with,
I swear, just just throw this back to people but with like hypotheticals
about people in the same way, the same kind of
like negative like monstrous implication hypotheticals. Just
throw them back at them in the same way, okay? Hey, no, I'm not
I'm not going to try. I'm not going to experiment. Never mind.
>> Brick Lane. Best curries in England. I love Birmingham,
fantastic place. >> Incredible incredible Bangladeshi curry.
I'll take you I'll take you there. >> Back to my my central
[clears throat] thesis here is that Dave This is the best This
is best Israel got at this point. Brown people are bad. Did you
know that? We We don't kill people. We're not terrorists. We
kill browns.
Those aren't people, guys.
Look at Do you like them in your country? Okay, but Okay, the
curry's good, but like
They're murderers.
Every liberal meanwhile, YES, THEY ARE they're murderers. I love
it when Adam says it. Hated it when Trump says it. Love it when
Adam or any member of the IDF or Israeli government says it.
Hate it when Trump says it. Love it when they say it. Awesome.
thinks that the United States military and the IDF are the equivalent
of the Ayatollah and the Hezbollah >> you've made that
point. Dave, final point here. Final point today. Just just I
think we all kind of agree that like open borders and lack of
immigration restrictions are not very sound policy and that those
ought to not be in place. But I do just want to say to the I
I guess almost brushed up against this Libertarians believe in
though? Don't Don't libertarians believe in open borders, Dave?
I didn't finish. Anyway, let me let me just finish one point,
Adam, since you have nothing to say. Just let me finish the point.
Anyway, no, Libertarians don't believe in open borders, Dave.
You've been in a body bag for about a year now. Yeah, great.
Great. Great. Okay, I've been in a body bag anyway. He's out
of the body [clears throat] bag now. Let's see Let's see what
the reaction to this debate is, okay? We'll take a look at that
when it comes out. It's actually crazy watching Adam do this.
Let's see what the reaction to this debate is, okay? We'll take
a look at that when it comes out. Anyway, the idea that my my
You're defending terrorism and you think the United States is
a terrorist organization. Yeah, right. Let's see what rational
MAGA people think. Go ahead, Dave. Let's Let's see. Okay, anyway,
the idea that you know, you're Let's see what rational MAGA people
think. That's how you know Adam is the logical smart guy. Let's
see what rational MAGA people think. Are the rational MAGA people
with in the room with you right now? You think those are the
people that podcast with you or who are those people >> general
Wesley Clark thing has been torn apart and that that By the way,
the rational MAGA people are the Israel first people, by the
way, okay? Never forget that. Totally rational. They are serving
their best interest. They're serving the interest that matters
most to them. It's just not you, okay? Yes, I am now I don't
know what to do other than to accuse Adam of dual loyalty cuz
what the [__] is he doing? He has no argument. He's
just here kvetching the whole time. There's no There's no reason
he should be doing this. I just think it's it's very obvious.
It's very telling. Every pro-Israel debater on the entire internet,
okay? Anybody with any amount of platform or popularity, MIA.
All gone. Everybody's left, okay? What do you think the reason
for that is? What do you think the reason for this embarrassing
moment for Adam Sosnick is?
Pretty clear if you think about it for 2 seconds. was my entire
case for Israel trying to push America into these wars is absolutely
ridiculous. There's much more to it than that. And that And that
point hasn't been torn apart. Piers, is anyone going to seriously
argue that Israel trying to push us into this war with Iran isn't
a factor? Has Benjamin Netanyahu, the longest-serving prime minister
in Israeli history, brags about how this is the culmination of
his entire life's work. >> Marco Marco Rubio Marco Rubio
Well, Marco Rubio Marco Rubio, Secretary of State, said it very
clearly that America preemptively got involved in the strikes
because Israel were going to attack Iran and so America thought
there would be revenge attacks against American interests and
got in first. And And Netanyahu's been coming here every other
week to try to lobby Trump into this war. Guys, so you guys are
you're saying that Trump is that I have to bring this to an end.
I love to continue
this. Please come Yes, obviously he is. And here's the thing.
That talking point should never work on anybody. That's obviously
true. Dave Smith likes Donald Trump. He doesn't want to say it.
Tucker Carlson likes Donald Trump. Doesn't want to say it. Joe
Kent likes Trump. Doesn't want TO SAY IT. BUT YES, Trump is a
[__] [__] Trump was dragged into this.
Absolutely.
I don't even believe that the Marco Rubio thing as I as I continue
to think about it, I don't think that's actually the best indication.
To me, the best indication is the intelligence stuff we've been
looking at. Like the reason they thought there could be some
uprising on the ground.
That's the most obvious thing. Everybody in the room who's American
saying, "Dude, [clears throat] this is not
Every person in the room who's Israeli
Donald, you need to understand that this is definitely going
to happen. It's right now. I can't do a Benjamin Netanyahu voice,
It's Oh, but also Lindsey Graham, who doesn't even have dual
loyalty. He has no loyalty to his own country. He is not an American.
Okay?
If you cannot charge him for sedition, send him to Israel.
Hopefully charge him for sedition, but if you can't, send him
to Israel. Try I'd love to have you come back again another time.
I've loved having you on. Dave, always good to see you. I've
sadly got to leave it there, but I appreciate it both very much.
Thank you.
Enjoy that
that's literally the worst I'm trying to think.
who did worse on the Piers Morgan
Who did worse?
Adam Sosnick or crackhead Barney?
Cuz I think it's Adam Sosnick. Remember crackhead Barney, that
flat that fat black woman with her tits out on Piers Morgan's
show? I'm pretty sure Adam Sosnick did worse. I don't think it's
close.
That's her bit. Adam Sosnick, I don't know what his bit is.
All right, now I want to keep I want to keep reading comments.
Also, I'm finished eating, so awesome. Just in time for the drama
stuff.
go. Oh, I need to add the hour to the stream as well. Give me
a second. 28,
Adam dressed himself for his own funeral. Oh, hold on. Adam thought
he was going against Vinnie on the PBD podcast. Trump found out
why seven previous administrations didn't attack Iran. What a
bomb. Glad to see Adam's first and last time on Piers. Adam is
never going on Piers Morgan again. I see why Adam doesn't do
debates. Almost 10,000 comments. I found two that were not ex-screening
all over Adam.
>> Thank you for this one. That lets me know that it's
just gold. I could just mine gold the whole way down. Thank you
so much.
Adam can't even debate a rock.
>> I like this one a lot. Adam can't even debate a rock.
Yes.
Dude, that's awesome. Adam can't even Adam can't even debate
a rock.
Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool.
So embarrassing for Adam. PBD would ask Adam for his to submit
his resignation.
Adam really showed up with the IQ of a goldfish. Who relies on
you, Adam? Your mom? Dude. How Piers can hold back laughing when
you see him want to laugh and smiling but trying to hold back
is priceless. Also, the only seal Adam knows is one he's is one
he fed a fish to at a at
Only seal.
What? Okay.
Really embarrassing for Adam. PBD should probably fire him. I
literally spent 30 minutes reading comments to try to find one
person in support of Adam, but couldn't. I've never had so much
that much second-hand embarrassment for someone like I just did
for Adam.
I have second-hand embarrassment for Adam. Adam doesn't even
know Okay, we're going to go until we see a a neutral comment,
okay? One that's not explicitly just only not Adam Sosnick, okay?
We're going to go
or 10 minutes, whichever comes first, okay? 10 minutes of reading
comments, 5 minutes of reading comments, or a a neutral comment,
okay? Just one that's not totally negative towards Adam. I'll
give it 5 minutes cuz I I don't want to read for 10 minutes.
Just got here still in the slot. You missed Adam Sosnick's career
as a debater start and end simultaneously.
Perhaps the worst showing on Piers Morgan I've ever seen.
I've seen some bad ones. I've watched a lot of this show. I've
never seen anything as embarrassing as what Adam just put out.
Absolutely brutal. So, now we're just reading comments. Adam
has proved that in modern America, the dumbest people really
do succeed. I also have to say "Do you get another
>> Can we go back to the mom comment? Hold on. I have to
go back to the Who do you take care of? Your mom? The regime,
do you mean all American presidents? Who's your favorite president
in the last 50
Adam, I'm 17 years old. I have a I have a wife and children.
Who depends on you, Adam? Your mom?
>> His face like dis- He malfunctions. >> wife and
children. Who depends on you, Adam? Your mom?
Adam, I actually have a girlfriend.
She's like 19. She's like 30 years younger than me, but I also
have a
Yeah, nobody asked.
You support You called the United States terrorist. That's really
mean.
Good one, Adam.